about to do my grocery shopping and buy
back cheese tuna fish shitty [ __ ]
ramen noodles my name is Matt I've been
out of college for seven years and one
of the main things I've noticed is how
much more money I spend on food today
then when I was in school I don't have
the strict type budget that I had in
college I went from ordering 5-5-5 deals
to probably spending most of my money on
meals and so I've wanted to revert back
to square one and that's college
three four dollar even though I ate like
such [ __ ] I just wanted to see how
eating like that again would affect my
day-to-day life because I gained 35
pounds my senior year college when
eating this exact type of stuff part
he's kind of looking forward to this
just finished myself ball game and
literally all I want to do is seamless
and food right now but college diet
cheesy delicious magic
I'm actually going to employ a little
trick I did in college heated my food up
with a blow dryer so a couple noodles is
still quite actually delicious but the
whole time I was eating I was wondering
why does this not seem healthy and then
I checked out the nutrition facts I just
had 50% my daily value of sodium this is
also going to be my dinner how it just
basically be exploited I was actually
thinking about it and all the junk food
that week has been genuinely delightful
I actually am getting a little too used
to eating it so I ate like college
student for a week I had mac and cheese
three nights for dinner like six cup of
noodles over the course of the week I've
saved close to 180 dollars I was like
holy [ __ ] I do not think it's a
sustainable way of living just because
I'm felt like a lot more lethargic
already feeling a little bit like poop
in my tummy which I don't love healthy
food I will admit that it does make you
feel a little better so I actually
brought home but I'm gonna pay more
attention to my seamless orders and I
will try to cook more often I will try
to actually grocery shop I will try to
be just a normal well-adjusted adult
instead of an overgrown college kid with
more money to spend